particle accelerators are a important
aspect of knowledge for nude and new
dimensions and new ideas and new
solutions therefore an essential part of
the scientific program which is
fundamental curiosity driven but it is
certainly capable of providing major
changes we are now going from a
situation in which very few people were
in science to a really truly science
driven Society the number of people
think is larger the question becomes
bigger in a certain sense also all the
simple questions been done and we only
left with a very difficult complicated
question we still deserve a lot of
consideration with so many people in so
many efforts
particle physics is being always the
crosswords in a sense the alternatives
are very many now today we are in a
situation which the LHC which is the
world unique world machine is now
capable of running and producing
presumably new results until a certain
time which is quite long we are talking
about 2037 as a deadline for end of the
LHC program that time seems to me a bit
too long because such time may require
also some additional development which
are now being prepared being studied but
there is something still missing which
we have to do about how the next
generation will be at the end of the LHC
and also beyond the LHC for which is no
information for the moment
first of all we have three generation of
elementary particles the fermions and
neutrinos are the neutral ones and the
charge per quark in and leptons are the
others but then we have also a forces
which are vector particles the W the
photon the W is a vector particle and
then the last great step forward has
been the discovery of a scalar particle
which is the Higgs particle the scalar
particle is a totally different particle
than the others therefore deserve to be
fully studied independently and the
surprises are different because the
particle is different